- [Voiceover] Hello, grammarians.
Let's talk about reflexive pronouns
and just as a word of warning,
this means I'm going to be
talking about myself a lot.
What I mean is that, in English,
we have this distinction between
the personal pronoun, so for example, me,
and its reflexive
pronoun, which is myself.
And we use these pronouns
in very specific cases.
So I'm gonna show you what all
of those reflexive pronouns look like
contrasted with their
personal pronoun forms
and then we're going to
talk about how we use them.
So in the first person we say
the personal pronoun is me,
the reflexive pronoun is myself.
The first person plural
personal pronoun is us
and the reflexive form
of that is ourselves.
Then in the second person,
both plural and singular
personal pronoun is you
and then, in the reflexive
it can be either yourself
when you're addressing one person
or yourselves when the
"you" you are talking to
consists of more than one person.
The singular third person
pronouns look like this
it, her, and him and
their reflective versions
are as follows... itself,
herself, and himself.
Finally, the personal pronoun them
becomes the reflexive pronoun, themselves.
Now, all of these are what we
would call object pronouns.
They can all be the object of a verb.
So they're never the do-ers,
they're always the do-ees.
With the exception of you or it,
none of these pronouns can be
the subject of a sentence.
In Standard American English,
it is not grammatical to say
"Me eat a cookie" for example.
It's part of why Cookie
Monster sounds so funny.
So then the question becomes,
when do you use these?
So the place for these
object pronouns to go
is in the back end of a sentence.
what we call the predicate,
where the object of the verb lives.
So, for example, "She poked me."
She is the subject of the sentence
and me is the object, is the
object of the verb poked.
It is the do-ee, it is
the thing that something
is done to not the do-er.
So that's when you'd use
object pronouns, generally.
But, when do you use reflexive pronouns?
You use reflexive
pronouns when the subject
and the object of a
sentence are the same thing.
Let me show you an example sentence.
Janelle made herself breakfast.
So in this sentence, herself and
Janelle are the same person
as opposed to the other
possibility which is
Janelle making breakfast for someone else.
Janelle made us breakfast,
and in this case, this
usage is not reflective.
She's not doing a thing
for herself or to herself.
She's making breakfast for other people.
And so, you'd just use the regular
personal object pronoun there.
You can only use the reflexive pronoun
when the subject and the object
of the sentence are the same thing.
Janelle is the same thing as herself.
Janelle is not the same thing as us,
so we would say us here and not ourselves.
How about this one?
Roderick saw me in the mirror.
Now I am not named Roderick.
I am not the same thing as Roderick,
and if I were writing a
sentence about myself,
I would say, I saw myself in the mirror.
Roderick and I, me, are
not the same person.
I and myself are the same person.
The same person as Roderick is Roderick.
So if we were to say,
Roderick saw Roderick in the mirror,
we would render that as,
Roderick saw himself
because the subject
here and the object here
are the same thing.
So remember, you use reflexive pronouns
when the subject and the object
of a sentence are the same thing.
It's really easy to get
tripped up this way,
especially if there's a
compound object in the sentence.
For example, you can
talk to Vidya or myself.
I see this all the time,
and in Standard American English
this is not correct because you
is not the same thing as me.
And it's easy to get confused because
you're talking about two people here
in this object and that's
a little befuddling.
It kind of throws you off.
And so there's a test you can do.
If you're unsure of whether or not
it should be Vidya or myself or
Vidya or me, which is what I would say,
how do you tell?
Take the other person out of the object,
just for a little bit.
So would you say, you can talk to myself
or would you say, you can talk to me?
Well, since we know you is not
the same thing as myself,
and you can only use reflexive pronouns
when the subject and the
object are the same thing,
the answer is me.
So then, we bring Vidya back,
we bring the other part
of the object back,
and it becomes, you can
talk to Vidya or me.
So when in doubt, sub it out.
Take the other part of the object
and just pretend it's not there
and just think about how the subject
and the object connect.
Chances are, you won't actually end up
using a reflexive pronoun.
Perform that little check
and you'll never go wrong.
You can learn anything. David out.